amo appena arrivo mi butto in spiaggia
non hai capito siamo già arrivati
ma doveva misure urgenti amore da tre
volte ac cosa senti ma stasera so
discorso piazza martin garlic che non so
se era un cantante quanto se santoro ma
tu ci sei non allora veniamo te la diamo
già di pioggia gli occhi cina non
mentono mai
mettiamo che statica e musica
andiamocene sotto casa voglio proprio
trentino aiutare informarmi da
dove toro non hanno mai a spacca di
brutto martin galli ho mandato un video
del gruppo tecnophone lettere mariga
madre del di oslo torniamo più bianca di
prima però c'è andata proprio de puta
madre siamo la sirena della eldo